much of the last 77 years yours of
schutz had lived in obscurity but on
tuesday that came to an end
despite all his attempts to conceal his
identity he could no longer hide his
past court has sentenced the accused to
five years in prison for aiding and
abetting murder and attempted murder the
court was convinced after having gone
through the evidence that the accused
had worked for three years as a guard at
the zucksenhausen concentration camp and
had supported the murders committed
there through his activities
today few of the barracks that house the
hundreds of thousands of prisoners
remain but reminders of nazi brutality
linger
this sign reads anyone crossing this
line will be shot without warning
it would regularly be patrolled by
guards
people like yules of schutz
the duties of a guard at this camp were
many and various but one of them was in
this building looking out on the camp
where you see all the barracks and
what's left of them why because here the
ss built a machine gun nest
to look in on the inmates because in the
view of the ss the inmates were the
threat this is where prisoners would be
murdered at first in small numbers but
then the nazis took to killing soviet
prisoners of war in the thousands
eventually gas chambers and a
crematorium allowed them to dispose of
the evidence of murder in secret the
prosecution maintained shuts could not
have not seen the processes that led to
the deaths of thousands
so why did it take more than 75 years to
bring shuts to justice
why were others like him left to live
out their lives
astrid lai works in the memorial site
here she told me that following the end
of the war many felt it important to
choose rebuilding their country over the
search for justice it took a long time
until a generation
grew up
who said we're going to stop this now we
can we want like like persons like this
uh judge lechterman today who's
completely
free of of the of the thought that he
has to kind of
um
keep it under under under the blanket
soon all those who played a role in the
murder of millions of innocent people
will be gone and germany will be left
with the question
why so few were ever brought to justice
dominic kane al jazeera at the former
saxon halls and concentration camp